STEPHANIE WONG: Hey.
It's day two of Next, and
wow, what an incredible day
one, right?
We had announcements around
data analytics, security,
sustainability, and
Google Workspace.
And now we're on to day two.
To give you a quick rundown
of what to look forward to,
we'll start the day with
the developer keynote.
You'll hear from the
leaders and developers
who are bringing our
latest innovations to life,
Google Cloud's vision for the
top three technology trends,
and how cloud computing will
evolve over the next decade.
And don't miss the live Q&A
hosted by my fellow developer
advocates.
For everyone looking to get more
out of your cloud investment--
which, let's face it, is
everyone-- check out the app
modernization spotlight, "Extend
the value of cloud investments
anywhere with Google Cloud."
Our VP of IaaS, VP
of app modernization,
and director of
product management
will be talking about how
we're extending our cloud
services to address more complex
and unique use cases from data
center to the edge.
You'll learn how to modernize
your people, processes,
and applications to take full
advantage of the distributed
cloud from Google.
Then join them for
a live Q&A session
to get your questions answered.
For security-minded
leaders-- which, once again,
should be everyone--
here's your chance
to listen to our very own chief
information security officer
and our VP of security.
They'll discuss how
to engineer security
directly into your
applications and platforms
to eliminate entire classes
of threats without friction.
They'll introduce the
invisible security vision
and discuss the key capabilities
that can make it a reality.
And, yes, we will
have a live demo
in this one, plus
another live Q&A.
Channel 2 of the
broadcast will include
a bunch of customer stories,
like Saber, Broad Institute,
Meow Wolf, and
Papa John's, on how
they're leveraging Google Cloud
Security, data platform, VMware
Engine, and more.
Don't forget we have learning
pathways to get hands-on.
Check out pathways for
cloud infrastructure, data
engineering and
analytics, Kubernetes,
hybrid and multi-cloud, ML and
AI, networking and security,
and more.
And we also have a multitude
of hands-on labs for Apigee,
Vertex AI, Cloud SQL, and more.
Check out all the
sessions with the ID HOL.
Enjoy day two of Next
and connect on social
by hashtagging
#GoogleCloudNext, and reach out
to me @stephr_wong.